I had had left the Democratic Party as
an assistant US attorney because I was
investigating a lot of corruption in
city government under John Lindsay and
even though John Lindsay was a
Republican who turned Democrat all the
people in city government would Nemec
rats and all these great society
programs which I kind of thought sounded
nice it looked like none of it was
getting to the poor people
[Music]
this is the report and I'm Dave Rubin
friendly reminder everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click that
notification bell so you're alerted when
new videos come out and joining me today
is the former mayor of New York City and
a special guest star of one of the best
ever episodes of Seinfeld Mayor Rudy
Giuliani welcome to the Rubin report
thank you very much so I could basically
spend I could spend an hour talking to
you about Seinfeld and something bit on
Saturday Saturday Night Live but I know
that there are probably probably some
more pressing things that you want to
get to but I thought what would be
interesting instead of just going into
all of the stuff of today which we will
get to is that especially for my younger
audience on YouTube that that sort of
know you as New York City's mayor and
and 9/11 that that version of you you
had a whole life and and a political
evolution before that that in many ways
is sort of like my political evolution
you you fought off the Mafia as Attorney
General and a whole bunch of stuff so
can we just do sort of Rudy Giuliani 101
I mean really from childhood childhood
on and then we'll get to the topics of
the day
I'll do it real quick I was born in
Brooklyn a second-generation Italian
American I went to a Catholic grammar
school then I moved from Brooklyn to
Long Island which was quite common in
those days and continued in Catholic
Grammar School what about ice canoeing
yeah in Garden City and North Bellmore
Long Island two different places and all
yeah but I went to high school in
Brooklyn
Bishop block on High School which was a
special diocesan school
in part because I wanted to be a priest
in my early days and kind of gave that
up when I found out there were things
called girls and I kind of didn't worked
with the priesthood then I went to
college in the Bronx in Riverdale
Manhattan College Law School at NYU
graduated law school and went became a
law clerk to a really fine federal judge
lloyd McMahon who taught me how to be a
trial war and then I entered the US
Attorney's Office at a very young age
and because of his training
I sort of started off as already a
pretty experienced trial water because
he he was a nice enough man to kind of
teach you what you have to do in the
courtroom and I love being a trial
lawyer I spent about five and a half
years doing that tried a hundred cases
as though the Mafia cases bank robbery
cases white collar cases income tax
evasion customs fraud just about
everything you can think of there are
federal crimes and then I was at I was
the head of the Narcotics Division which
in those days was focused a lot on the
French Connection the Italian French
heroin trade the Colombian trade all the
Colombian cartel people that was the
first time that somebody put out a
contract to kill me Vito Genovese his
brother-in-law threatened to have me
killed because I prosecuted him and he
got convicted the combien cartel
threatened to slit my throat but I was
like 25 26 years old and you know I
don't know you feel immortal in though
in at a younger age then I went off to
Washington to be the deputy chief of
staff to the Deputy Attorney General
Harold Tyler in the Ford administration
and that's where I started to think
about I had a pack left the Democratic
Party as an assistant US attorney
because I was investigating a lot of
corruption in city government under John
Lindsay
and even though John Lindsey was a
Republican who turned Democrat all the
people in city government would Nemec
rats and all these Great Society
programs which I kind of thought sounded
nice it looked like none of it was
getting to the poor people it was all in
the hands of the administrator of the
program his wife some of the crooked
minority politicians in the city the
white quickly came to realize didn't
really care about their community just
cared about getting rich for themselves
very disillusioned I changed my
registration from Democrat to
independent then I went off and I worked
for two years in the Ford administration
met a lot of Republicans and found out
that they really weren't terrible my
impression from New York were you know
Republicans only care about rich people
and they're really very mean and turned
out they were just as caring about poor
people they just had a different way of
trying to move them out of poverty kind
of made more sense to me they can move
people out of poverty through worked and
welfare I kind of had always a strong
aggressive foreign policy with regard to
Soviet so I was sort of a Kennedy
Democrat in those days there was a
fellow named Stu Jackson a senator who
was a very hard liner on foreign policy
so then I switched to being a Republican
I said well let me try the Republican
Party when it's a law practice works for
Ronald Reagan's election and Ronald
Reagan made me the third ranking
official in the Justice Department I did
that it came back to New York I became
the US Attorney I prosecuted the five
families to the Mafia over 800 mafia
people a large number of Wall Street
criminals boesky probably being the most
famous one Milken prosecuted three or
four sitting congressmen and also
started using the racketeering statute
in a way that hadn't been used before to
break up organized crime we took over
the Teamsters Union drove out organized
crime we took over the casinos and most
Vegas and got rid of them we took over
the Fulton fish market the the whole
industry of the garment industry and
Rangeley mafia controlled the gay boss
in New York and a combination of our
work and then the advent of hiv/aids got
rid of those places but the Mafia owned
those bars for purposes of extortion
owned every single one you couldn't open
a gay bar in New York and not have Vito
Genovese and his his number two guy walk
in on you and tell you that he owned
half the bar say why and they stayed
because if we don't we break you will
break your kneecap so we got them out of
there and I had a very and then I catch
this thing that made me famous as as the
mayor was i prosecuted a number of the
high-level official from the conscient
ministration its chief political allies
and proved that they were involved in a
multi-million dollar bribery scheme to
collect find and divert them to to their
own pocketbooks to the tune of about 15
or 20 million dollars a year geez that
gave me a great deal of name recognition
and I got the crazy idea of running for
mayor all my friends told me I was nuts
the Republican couldn't win I thought
maybe I was nuts but I was young enough
to try to be nuts and find out if I
would enjoy politics I was lucky enough
to get David Garth as my political
advisor I started off but 27 points
behind I lost by two David taught me how
to be a political candidate and it was
the best showing a Republican had made
in 40 years since LaGuardia
I got 48% of the vote and I guess if I
had gotten 20 I'd have given up but 48%
of the vote I said to myself maybe I can
have another chance to do this and then
you eventually decided to do it again
and the residents were you so later four
years later I did it again and I won by
a very narrow margin but 3% and then I
ran for re-election four years later I
won by a landslide and I was very
fortunate I made a lot of promises I
really went into the job with the notion
that this is the first Republican in two
generations I might be the last
Republican mayor of New York why not
just do everything I wanted to do and if
I had worked I'd be a hero and if it
didn't they'd throw me out and maybe 20
years later they realized I was trying
to do the right thing I really had that
attitude so I yeah
but city government I cut city
government to what it should be by about
20 percent
I laid off enormous numbers of people I
decrease everything in city government
and interestingly but the police
department because I had I had couple
years before I before I was mayor over
here 2,200 murders
and we had about 1.1 billion people on
welfare we had ten nine percent
unemployment and we had a deficit that
was said to be about 700 million a
trillion with 1.4 billion and we had a
situation with 75 percent of the people
in the city wanted to leave so I ran on
very much but the the things that Donald
Trump he is four years ago which I might
say I kind of suggested he's I said you
can't do what he was how King out to New
York's did he be any worse been leading
the country in crime murder violent
crime white-collar crime organized crime
drugs we were heading everything if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell